Hey everyone, it's Michael Altos here
and this is the order flows market
analysis for Wednesday, February 22nd,
2017. And today, you know, the Dow
posted its ninth straight record close,
although you know, barely. It was I
think it was just like uh 2 of a percent
at uh 2775.
Existing home sales came out today and
you know, they posted some solid
increases despite uh you know, lesser
homes being on the market. and the FOMC
minutes came out and you know
surprisingly I was a little bit shocked.
I thought uh you know Fed officials were
more
ready to raise interest rates at the
last meeting um sort of based off of
what was being said in the last week but
anyway um you know we got the next
meeting in March and you know we'll see
what uh what transpires then and you
know oil moved down below 54 bucks a
barrel. So, you know, before we jump in,
brief disclaimer. This presentation is
for educational andformational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. So, there's four tools I'm
going to be showing you in this
presentation. It's the order flows
trader footprint chart and a few of my
proprietary indicators, the flip, the
U-turn, and the transition. So, you
know, it's very very uneventful day in
the S&Ps and you know, we we you know,
just looking on a 10 range chart real
quick, I'll pull it in.
It's it was basically flatline um most
of the day. I mean, you know, there
really wasn't much. I mean, we did have
the Fed minutes come out, but still
beyond that, you know, basically between
55 and we got down to 55 and a quarter
um you know, around 6:00 in the morning,
you know, our overnight high 63 and 75.
63 spot 75 and we just surprisingly we
we traded in that range the entire day.
um you know off this low here you did
have a divergence but you know we did
sort of get up near the high just after
1:00 but you know for the whole entire
day we've basically you know we were
contained so you know it's
you know it's one of those narrow range
7 days probably I haven't looked at a
daily chart but you know out of these
very quiet days you know oftent times
that's going to lead you know probably
tomorrow or the next day into you know
into some pretty volatile uh market
conditions. You know, I wouldn't be
surprised to see the market um you know,
put in a big move
either tomorrow or or the next day. You
know, that that's what I would be
looking for after a day um you know,
like today where you're trading
where you're trading in in such a in
such a tight range. You know, it's think
of it like this, right? It's a rubber
band. You take the rubber band, wrap it
around your fingers, and then let go. um
you know and you see how the rubber band
just snaps everywhere or not everywhere
but you know picks up a lot of uh motion
and you know spins around and slaps and
hits you in the face. But um regardless
I mean you know the what the the level I
was looking at today which I'm surprised
we didn't reach. I thought there was a
few times we were going to hit it. Of
course we'd have to take out the high
was yesterday's high at 22 sorry 22
2365.
Um I even drew a blue line in there.
I'll keep it in for tomorrow. I wouldn't
be surprised if you know we make a run
up at it. But, you know, this this
morning in in the order flow, there were
really there was some false starts. Um,
you know, go here to where the cash
opened. Um, this is after the cash, you
know, 835.
Yeah, this was the delta surge. Again, I
really wasn't interested in it. Then
coming down here,
you know, you have the three in a row.
One, two, three. And
you ended up with four ratios. So you
got one, two, three ratios, then a
fourth one, you know, then the green
bar. I I like to get the green bar in
here. So I'm looking for a pullback in
between um the third and the second bar
between the points of controls, which
would be here at 57 to 57 1/2. You know,
kept trading down. You know, we popped
back up here to 6 1/2.
You got this dogee bar here. Then we
started pulled back up to 7 and a4. But
again, it's quite far we moved away. you
know, I don't like to um,
you know, get a signal here and then be
taking the trade way over here. I'd be
looking to take the trade, you know,
within the next bar or two or three
even. You know, once you're getting four
bars away from, you know, the the last
bar of a three bar setup, I mean, what,
you know, do do you really want to take
it? It may work, it may not. Um, but
really, you know, I'm looking to get in
a little closer to, you know, where the
entry, uh, you know, where the signal is
kicking off. Not, you know, after you
make a little bit of a move down
already, then start retracing back up.
Because what's going to happen often
times is, you know, you're coming down,
you're coming down. You know, ideally,
you'd like to be getting short. You'll
be liking to get this green candle here
and get the pullback within this bar or
this bar and then make the move. Not go
down, go down, continue on down, and
then get a pull back up here. Because
what's going to happen often times is
you're going to keep going down down
down, you know, past your entry, past
your signal bar,
you you get down to a low area and then
you start working your way back up. And
you know, at this point, you don't
really want to be short anymore because
it's going to have a tendency to keep
going back up. And you know, we just
sort of hung around here actually
and you know, eventually we sort of came
back up. But you know even if even if
you you know you you got shorted here in
between these two at 7 and a quarter if
you're miraculous you were able to sell
7 and a quarters here or say you sold
sevens you know this is at uh what time
is that you know 8:42 you know then
you're just hanging around here all this
time you know it's going nowhere you
know just you know don't stay in it you
know the move is not happening at this
point you know get out um then there was
another
came up here. Now, this yellow line
here, right, that's the opening price.
And on on days, that's going to be
trendless, you know, or I say trendless,
but no direction. You know, you tend to
find the opening price and just sort of
hang around unchanged all day. And, you
know, there was a move here. I thought,
you know, maybe this is it. This could
be the area where we pop up and take out
the high. This was
uh around 9:38 this morning. And so
we're above the opening price, you know,
the value area at that time,
you know, was was down in here, you
know, much much lower actually. Um it
was around 58 and a half was the upper
area of the value area. So we're moving
away from value, right? And I'm always
looking for the times when the market's
moving away from value to find another
value area. And you know, I'm thinking,
hey, you know, now we're we're maybe
we're possibly doing it. You know, we
got the Delta surge kicking off. We've
got a stacked imbalance here. And I
thought maybe we could. You know, this
bar sort of ees up and then you run into
this bar, right? The high is this green
line, high of the day here. And remember
at 65, which is just above is
yesterday's high. So I thought, you
know, looking at this, you know, hey,
maybe this is it. Maybe we're going to
finally take out the high. But what you
get up here, right, you get this, you
know, what people like to refer to as
minus development, which is, you know,
the market not doing what it's supposed
to do, right? which is just as important
as the market doing what it's supposed
to do. You know, people get so caught up
trading, you know, with with indicators
that, you know, if an indicator says buy
here, right? It doesn't say, well, if
doesn't buy here, sorry, if it says buy
here and sell there, but you know, if
you're reading the order flow, you can
see this minus development. So, you
know, even though normally, you know,
these imbalances here, buying imbalances
on a bar that's turning down, you know,
that's minus development. Why? Because
you got these buying imbalances, you
expect the market to continue up, keep
going up, right? I mean, you know,
normally when you get a couple
imbalances stacked on each other's is
buying imbalances, it's bullish for the
market. But in this case, it didn't
happen. This is minus development. And
what happens is is the market comes
down. So, you know, at this point, you
know, what's causing this minus
development? What's causing that to
happen? Well,
you got to imagine, right? This green
line is the high and we're sign finally
getting on the other side of value area,
right? We're trading high. We're above
the opening price. We're up here near
the highs. People are coming in and
saying, "Hey, this is it." Especially
after, you know, for the last couple
weeks been, you know, almost every day
we've been making new highs in the
contracts. And no, it's 9:40 in the
morning. We're we're up near the highs.
People are saying, "Hey, I better jump
in. We're going to go rally 10 points."
So that's why you got all these buying
imbalances here and here, right? You've
got aggressive buying people lifting the
offers. You know, I don't know if
they're retail traders. I don't know if
they're institutional traders. I I don't
know. All I know is they're wrong,
right? That's what the order flow is
telling me. The price action in the
order flow is telling me because why
aren't we trading up here? Why didn't we
take out, you know, the high at 3 and
3/4 and trading four? Because there's
sellers up in here. There's people up
here to sell to the buyers, you know,
willing to offer it. Even when it goes
bid here, you know, 1794, you know,
sellers came in and sold it to them,
right? And then the market drifts back
down. So, you know, this is a case of
the market not doing what you'd be
expecting it to do. Everyone's piling
in. You got the aggressive buyers. You
got these big imbalances, but at the
same time, it's met with resistance. You
know, it's met with sellers, people that
got a lot of supply up here that they're
willing to sell. So you know this is at
22 uh sorry 22 23 63
and we we sell off you know down back
down around the opening price at 60 just
sort of hanging around there again I
can't get interested you know taking any
sort of you know imbalances or whatever
around the opening price because you
know on slow days look I mean look at
this you've got imbalance uh you got
point of control right at the opening
price again another one another one
another one another one you know it's
just lining up right there no direction
whatsoever ever at all. Um, you know,
then we start creeping back up again.
You know, 62 1/2 here. You seeing some
volume come in. You've got, you know, a
buying balance in there and the market
gets smacked down again. You know, this
arrow is drawn by the software just to,
you know, highlight, hey, idiot. You
know, you've got a a stack buying
imbalance at the top of a red bar. You
know, it's a ratio as well. So, it's
telling you there's some stopping
volume, you know, right right here,
right now. Um, you know, then you just
sort of hang around here. one bar, two
bars, you know, you get up to the next
one and then you make the move from um,
you know, so if you know 62ish area, you
know, if you're getting short here at 62
based off of this this point of control
at the high, you know, this arrow
telling you, hey, there's a buying
imbalance at the top of the bar, which
is on a down candle, which is bearish,
right? And, you know, I said you just
hang around here. I mean, he does get up
to 62 and a half before selling back
down, you know, down down down down
below um, you know, to the 58s, 57 and a
half. This here is the, you know, it's
1:00 at this point. Honestly, you know,
you had the minutes come out, FOMC
minutes come out at 1. I I don't think
you'd be trading around that time
anyway. But nevertheless, you know,
reading what's been going on in the
order flow, you know, this is the delta
surge given a buy here and you know,
just trades up a little bit and but
again, we just sort of hang around this
opening price. You know, it's a
directionless really a directionless
day. We get back up to two, you know,
again, hit two. There's just nothing,
you know, then we we close the day up
here at uh was at two and a quarter. So,
you know, not much going on in the S&Ps
this morning, um, really to talk about.
So, let's take a look at,
you know, look at the five years, right?
I I I have the the five years. You five
years were interesting. Um I'll take a
look at the bonds in a second but you
know 5 years what I found very
interesting and you know it's something
that again you know you can only see if
you're looking at the order flow and to
a certain extent the uh volume profile
is this was at uh around 8:45 this
morning this area in here at 118 even
look at this volume you're seeing here
6,000
3,000 4,000 10,000 4,000 5,000 2400 you
know add that up real quick I mean just
rough roughly 6,200 plus 3,700 plus
4700.
You know that's already this is you know
the these three prices here is already
almost 15,000 lots. Then you got another
10,000 and you know 4,000 cents. So this
is 15,000 here plus another 5,000 plus
another two. So um you know this is you
know over 20,000 contracts here. So
15,000 at this level. I'm just talking
these these three bars here. I'm not
talking about anything else. Yeah, your
point of control for the day was at this
point was obviously this 118 or 11731
and uh 3/4
you got 15 you know you got 10,000
15,000 there another um you know what is
that I I say 20 20ome thousand so you
know 30 some thousand contracts traded
within you know a half hour right at
this area so what I'm looking at you
know I I I'm looking at it when we're
trading down here at 31 one, you know,
if we can stay down here, you know, it
could be very bearish for the money.
This is your resistance level, right?
You know, and so we pop back up and we
get through it actually by a couple
ticks here, it's not the end of the
world, right? When you're dealing with
resistance levels or support levels, you
know, people can tend to get fixated
thinking it's got to be that one price,
you know, 118 even. So, if we trade 118
even and a quarter, oh, the level
failed. No, it's not. You know,
sometimes you you poke through it for
whatever reason, okay? Just because you
poke through it by a tick or two doesn't
necessarily mean that it fails.
And what happens, you know, over the
next hour, 9:00, boom, boom, boom. You
know, from 118, even we'll call it 117
31 12. Where' we trade down to? Um,
all the way down to uh 28,
you know, and even even lower later.
Again, I'm not going to say you'd be
holding it all the way till to the the
announcement of the minutes, but um you
know, we did trade all the way down from
the to the lows, but you know, but
realistically, you know, from 17
uh 3031 rather, you know, down to 11728,
that's a beautiful move to get in the in
the 5 years in an hour or so. Now, the
bonds, you know, people, you know, bonds
wasn't as pretty as
as the five years were. The five years,
you know, it really it really just it
really just stood out. Um, where's my
bond chart here?
Whoops.
U, you know, bonds and fives, you know,
move together, but, you know, sometimes
it it takes a takes a while for them to
move in the same direction. You know,
one may be ticking up a little bit while
the other one's ticking down. and and
back and forth like that. But um
this is the bonds this morning.
Really wasn't much either in the bonds.
Just like the S&Ps, I didn't really find
anything worth uh worth trading. But
where are we here? Go back here. We had
the high, you know, this was
interesting. We had this high here at uh
750 this morning. You do have a
divergence. Nothing else. Um you just
sort of go sideways. You trade back up
to it. you get within two ticks of that
high, you trade back to that point of
control, right? Um, take this off. That
a little smaller so it's easier to see.
So, what do you got here?
Point of control of this bar is right
here. You know, when you trade, you
trade it right back up to it. This is a
setup that I have written about
many times, you know, and it's on my
website. I've recorded multiple videos
on. It's called the O2X. And what it is
is you have the high and you pull back
within two ticks of that high. Literally
two ticks. And your stop is just going
to be right here, right above that high.
So, you know, you can be getting short
at 04. It did go bid there. So, if you
were working an offer at 04, you would
have been filled. And you know, your
stops at 07, so it's a three tick stop.
and we came right back up there to 04
and then sold off um you know all the
way down to you know the 20s mid 20s. Um
eventually we did go lower, but you
know, for me, you know, getting five,
six ticks, you know, out of a out of a
bond trade is is good enough, especially
if you got a a three tick stop. You
know, you get, you know, 2 to one is is
good. You know, I mean, you could have
been patient and held on, you know, for
another half hour and gotten a heck of a
lot more. Um, you know, I mean, it
traded all the way down to 08. So,
again, you know, I'm not saying you
you'd be holding it until the FOMC
minutes came out down in here. Oh, it's
not down here. This is about a half hour
before it opened. Now, you know, I talk
about when you have multiple
divergences,
we'll look for the market to keep going
lower. Although, you know, what's the
time? 12:51. By the time you got the
third divergence, 1:00 is when the
minutes come out. You know, you don't
want to be sitting in a trade thinking,
I think this market's going to go lower.
And then you got to sit through a big uh
data, not data, but you know, a
fundamental
um release, you know, the minutes. So,
and then you can see how it just
snapped, you know, over this is 1:00,
you know, 1:00, 2 seconds, 9 seconds, 20
seconds, 54 seconds. So, you know, this
is 101 and 35 seconds, 102 and 19
seconds. So, you can see how volatile it
is when the minutes were released.
So, I mean, you know, any anything
you're doing, you know, right up to
1250, you know, forget it, you know,
forget it. you can't take that analysis
going into the release of
release of that report. Um, you know, so
again, you know, and then after that,
you know, there's there was some
movement, but really at that point, I'm
really not interested, you know, even
though you do have a racial bounce low
here, blah blah blah. Um, you know,
single print here, you know, we trade
back up there twice. Okay. But you know
honestly after those minutes come out I
like to give it at least 15 minutes to
settle down and sort of the market to
sort of find its footing back and then
where were you? You're back at
unchanged.
So you know those were the the order
flow. Now when you're looking at the
indicators
um and we'll start with the 987 charts
today.
Uh
I haven't looked at all these charts yet
actually. I've looked at a few. I was
watching a few of these, but this one I
haven't looked at, but I want to pull it
up. I'll talk about it.
Nothing really in the Euro currency. Um,
go back.
Anything earlier? No, nothing earlier.
So, you had two signals here. This one
and then this one. You know, this one
worked. This one obviously didn't.
Um, you know,
not going to hide it from you. If it
didn't work, it didn't work. I'll show
you bonds. Uh, you know, bonds were were
nice. Honestly, I wasn't watching it on
the bonds. I didn't notice it until, you
know, 2:00.
But, you know, there was this is the
transition, right? Settings. Same
settings. That's on the Euro currency. 3
100 400 3400.
Look at this. Go back. That's overnight.
Nothing. Uh, well, basically, it's in
seven. There's nothing. We got a sell
here at uh you know what is that 15128
the area between 28 and and the figure
but that's it sold off all the way down.
Again I'm not saying you hold it all the
way up until 1:00 but you know it's just
sort of going here going you know just
you know poking in your favor a bit you
know hanging around break even before it
makes the the nice move. Again, this is
a
you know, from I don't want to say from
20, you know, 15128 to 15028, but you
know that that's
that's a that's a $1,000 move right
there on a on a one contract. So, you
know, that was it in the uh then later
here. Okay, this is just around the
close 2:00. So, okay, so there were two
trades in this one. Yeah, it did sort of
go down lower. Right now, we're in the
evening session. and we're trading uh
15114.
So, but again, I'm not saying you'd hold
it until the next session,
you know, by by 2:00. I'm done. I'm done
with the bonds.
2:00. Why? That's the old floor close
hours. And why did the floor close at
those that time is because um you know,
that's basically when the cash market
closed. No point in trading bonds when
the cash is closed. Now, E- Minis 987
tick chart. This time again, you know,
these have been the 987 tick, right? The
bonds, uh, Euro currency. Now, the E-
Minis. So, here, uh, this is 9
around 940. You get a sell. Boom, boom,
boom. Again, you know, let the market
take you in. Just cuz you get a buy
here, just don't go ahead and buy and
then place your stop down there. If you
could, well, think about it. What would
you rather have? I'd rather have give up
a two ticks for the market to take you
in and get a more accurate trade rather
than risk, you know, a point, you know,
four ticks and get stopped out. I'd
rather let the market take me in like
this one, right? You have your low of
this bar, you know, so you take your
entry, you know, you look, okay, let the
market take me in. So the say this low
is 62, you know, I say, okay, if we
trade down to 61 and a half, I want to
be in. Like here it's 60. We'll call
this 60 and and a half. Okay, if the
market goes up to 61, yeah, okay, then
I'll be in. Okay, it doesn't. So you're
not in.
Um, you know, this one, you know, this
would have taken you in. I don't think
you would have got much out of there.
Probably would have scratched this other
trade in here.
This one I don't think you would have
been taking it because even though it
did sell off, it looks nice. Again, it's
right going up until 1:00 and I wouldn't
be trading, you know, any anything at
1:00.
Uh crude. Let's see if I got a crude
chart in here.
987 tick.
I think there was I don't know there was
on the crude. I said, you know, crude is
around 54 bucks. So, there was some
sells here, it looks like.
Okay. So, going back here's a buy
started poking up. Didn't work out.
This one, you know, the next bar. No.
No. Then here started giving you some
signs. Okay. Maybe this one,
you know, you're only talking 47 down to
46. You should be giving it more than
one tick. I think like here, I'm not
saying, oh, you know, this low is 54,
you got to get in at 53. No,
realistically I'd be looking, you know,
um 51, 52, 51.
You know, this one probably would have
stopped you out. This one again, some
similar 54 got down to 52.
So, I don't know. You know, that one is
probably safe to say it didn't work that
great in the crude, but you know, in a
couple markets, you know, those lights
out. Uh
the flip real quick. Um this is my Dow
10 range chart.
Yeah, this one didn't really go
anywhere. It gave you a sell here. Did
go down down down, but still not much to
get excited about there. Uh
what else?
All
right, this is the U-turn here. Um, so a
three- range chart. Okay, I'm not really
too interested, you know, what's going
on at 5 or 6:00 in the morning, but
there is, you know, did give you a buy
right on the low of the day. But
regardless, um, you know, here, not
really here, a little bit of something.
You know, this one, this high, it did
work out quite nicely. This
swing low. Yeah. Okay. I don't know.
It'll be close to getting you stopped
out. This one didn't work out.
But again, that's 1:00. Um, you're not
going to be taking any trades there.
This was, you know, 2:00.
I'm not sure, you know, if I'd be
looking to be trading,
you know, after the minutes come out. I
mean really, you know, the market was
very dead quiet all day and then you got
the minutes come out and the market just
sort of goes back and forth and is doing
nothing again. That doesn't lead towards
a good uh you know towards a good
I don't know what the word is um good
trading opportunities. You know, you'd
want to see the after the after the
minutes come out, you'd want to see, you
know, take out the high or the low or
something sort of movement, but you're
just not getting anything. So, it's hard
to get uh get excited at all on that.
The last one I'll show you is the So,
what was that? That was the U-turn.
This one is the uh one of my favorites.
I'll say my favorites is the chart that
I like looking at nowadays is the YM,
the mini dow, the
10 the 100 tick chart. Okay, let just
get it up here.
Okie dokie. Um, again, you know, stay
away from the 1:00 time. And going back,
this is pre-cash. You know, the cash
opens here. You get a sell, didn't work
out. You get some buys that did, you
know, the sell worked out. This buy
worked out
again. You know, this one sell here, I
probably wouldn't be interested because,
you know, it didn't go any further down.
So, you know, you'd be interested in
this long. Yeah, this one. And you again
it ticked by a tick or two
then eventually came through. But you
know these are much clearer, right? Blow
it up.
You know where you get the buy. Then the
next bar is clearly up. You know just
like here you get the buy. The next bar
or two is clearly up
again. Next bar two is clearly up.
Just like the down bar here. This up bar
here.
This one. No. This one. Maybe
11:00,
you know, going into 1:00. Yeah, I don't
think you're going to be taking anything
12:30.
Uh, okay. I'm not really interested in
this. You know, I said you just give it
15 minutes to rest. I mean, if if you
took it, you know, you'd be stopped out
here a small, you know, maybe break
even. You know, 2:00 maybe you could be
looking to take it, but again,
you know, I'd like to see some sort of
reaction from the market. There was
none. You know, we're sort of back to
trading
nowhere.
You know, late in the day, we did get
another another another after the close
rally from 45 up to 70, but that's not
much of a rally. You know, this was a
nicer one from this area.
You know, what is that? 7:30 up to uh
765.
So, yeah, I showed you the three
indicators and the orderful footprint
chart
and how they performed today. Um, you
know, so not bad. You know, I mean, in
the crude oil wasn't that good, but you
know, you got some nice moves in the
minis, the mini Dow,
the
bonds was was a beautiful move. Let me
see if I got another chart I could show
you. Again, it's uh yeah, I'm not trying
to just pick these charts. These are the
same charts that I show you pretty much
every single day. Um
yeah, the people say, "Oh, you're just
showing the charts that it work." No,
you these are the same sets of charts I
I show you guys every single day. you
know, the 987 tick chart, the 100 tick
987 tick chart, you know, on those
different contracts, the um 100 tick
chart on the mini Dow,
you know, the footprint chart on the
four range bonds, you know, on the three
range S&Ps and, you know, so it's not
like I'm out here trying to, you know,
just, you know, pick these things um
and and show you, you know, when they
work. But, you know, anyway, I'll show
you this chart. This is the Euro
currency, right? This is an eight range
chart. Now, this is everything thrown up
and on there. Not everything, but you
know, the U-turn, the transition, and
the flip. And, you know, it confuses.
You know, people tend to think that,
hey, you know, if I got one indicator
that works halfway decent, if I put more
indicators on, you know, I'll be three
times as good, right? If I've got three
indicators. It doesn't work that way
always. And part of the problem is
people don't know how to separate the
trades. you know, they think, well, I'll
just, you know, trade it from here to
here and then there there. And and it's
it's it's wrong because, you know, each
one, you know, works differently. So,
you know, just really quick, you like
the arrow is the flip. You know, these
the blue and the red arrow is the flip,
the hash is the U-turn, and the
transition,
I don't think there was one on here
today. The transition is like a a cross
sign. Um
yeah, there's not. But um
yeah, but anyway, so this is an eight
range chart. So you when you throw all
three up on there, you know, it looks a
lot messy, you know, and you're going to
have some that failed and some that you
know like you know this, okay, this is
the transition here. So I mean, you can
see here, right? You got this double
bottom, you've got the U-turn, you know,
at a double bottom. You know, you got to
sometimes you got to apply
all your knowledge of trading when you
trade. You know, people think, "Oh, I
got an indicator. I can just kick back
and print money for my new ATM." No,
it's it's not like that. Um, you still
got to think of these things. You know,
if you get, you know, the the U-turn,
which you know, obviously U-turn, it
should be a reversal indicator. You
know, you should be happening at an
area. So if you're looking at it
actually, you know, it's actually a
triple I say quadruple bottom, but again
this is 1:00, you know, nevertheless
it's it's giving you those the same
technical um signs. You know, here
you're sort of coming into a base and
here 130 123 124. You know, you're
looking for a low. You get a swing low.
You get a sign here with the U-turn.
Just as up here, you're sort of peaking
up here. You get a sign up here to get
short and then it comes down in here.
Okay, at this point maybe the low hasn't
been found yet. It doesn't happen for
another couple bars and you find your
low and then you go back up and then you
come back in here. You get another swing
high and you work your way down, you
know, from this is at
250 252, you know, right now in the
evening session trading down here at uh
at 61
or 10560. So, you know, it's gone down
from basically the 77 75 area down into
the 60 area. Um, you know, and then it
it's it it's confusing for people
sometimes, you know, the more they put
on a chart,
the more confused you get. You know, I
mean, I I understand that, you know,
people think that, hey, you know what?
If I got this one indicator and it works
nice, then if I just put another
indicator on, you know, it's going to
give me more trades and more trades. No,
don't don't do that. You're going to get
yourself in a lot of trouble because
then you're going to be you know getting
out of trades too early because you know
what there's a signal here and then
there's a sign you know you have a sell
here rather than trading this you get a
buy signal here so you got to get out
you know this one fails and then the
market keeps going you know you could
have rode this one out maybe a little
bit more I mean you know it's there's a
lot that goes into it rather than just
throwing up an indicator on your chart
and you know and thinking okay I could
just turn it loose especially if you
don't understand how to use it, you
know, and and I get people that don't
understand how to use it. I mean, no, no
offense to them, but, you know, at least
take the time to to learn what, you
know, what you should be looking at,
what you should be looking for in terms
of, you know, is is this a reversal
indicator? Is this continuation
indicator or what? You know, I mean,
oftentimes, you know, people, I don't
care. I just want to put it on my chart
and get turn it loose and um you know
get to work on it. Um
see if there's any other
any other useful charts I could run
through real quick here.
put that on there. I thought I had a one
minute chart of the E- Minis.
But anyway, um just bear with me for one
second.
I I can't find it here. I I wanted to
show you another chart of the U-turn,
but
I just can't find it here. Okay, wait
here. I think I've got it.
Okay, so anyway, this is a E- Mini. It's
a one minute chart. Again, this is with
every, you know, with kitchen sink
thrown on it. Uh, let's make it a little
bit bigger so it's easier to see.
Scrunch it up a bit. So, again,
this hash is the U-turn. This looks like
a square box. If you open it up, it's
actually a it's actually a cross. That's
the transition. You could change all
these things if you want, but um let's
just sort of scroll back to around the
cash open and walk you through it here.
Cash open. Okay. So, the U-turn is
giving you here a couple buy signals.
The market goes up. You know, these sell
signals don't work.
You know, the market's going a little
bit higher still. Again, this one fails
transition sells right down into this
low where you get a uh you know a
bullish signal. Again, you know, I say
you let the market take you in, right?
Just as here you have a sell signal.
Well, which way to take? Okay, if it's a
reversal indicator, okay,
you want to move to reverse. This I
don't consider a move that you're
reversing. This I do. Right? You're
coming down here, you get a buy signal,
and then you're starting to go up and
it's it's not really that much higher
than any of these previous bars. It's
equal high to the previous bar. And even
the fourth bar and fifth bar, it's still
below. So, it's it's not really a move
to reverse yet. So, you know, people
will say, ah, you know, it gives a buy
here and it gives a sell here. Well,
it's reading the order flow, right? It's
not a red light, green light
trading system, you know, read what's
going on in the market, you know? So, if
it's a reversal, the U-turn is
specifically by the name U-turn means
reverse. So, if you're trading something
to reverse, have a move to reverse. You
don't have a move here that's ready to
reverse,
you know. So, if you could overlook
this, you know, at least you would have
got this move and then you have a move
up here that's giving you a sign to
reverse. So, you go from there down to
here. Again, this was a very tight range
day. Um, these these buys, it just goes
sideways on you here. Um
again, you know, this one, yeah, maybe
if it just goes sideways on you again,
another one sideways on you. Uh this is
coming into the two to the the FOMC
announcement. Um you know, 2:00. Is this
a move? You know, honestly, you ask
yourself this. You know, you're looking
at this. Say, you know, you're coming up
on this this signal here. Okay, it's
1:55
in the afternoon. Okay, I got a signal.
What should I do? Get short? Well,
it it would probably be a lot more
efficient if this if this bar was
trading up here around 62 and a half,
not at, you know, 60 or 60 and a half,
which is where you've just been trading.
You've been in this zone, in this range
for the last hour. You know, at least up
here at two, right? You have a move up.
if you've been working your way up that
maybe it's it's it's a decent location
trade location for taking a short I
wouldn't be interested in getting along
off of cuz that's where you've just been
you know hanging around trading at these
areas at least here is after a you know
I'll say a move cuz this market didn't
really move today but you know where
you'd rather be getting short you know
at 62 or down here at 60
and the market's just going sideways you
get some back and forth stuff here. This
is right ahead of the close. You know,
we reopened. We're in the night session
right now. I'm recording this. It's 5:00
in the afternoon, 5:17
um or whatever. And so anyway, we're
trading down here at uh 6062
right now. So anyway, um so thanks for
taking the time to watch this. You know,
to learn more about the trading software
and these indicators using this
presentation and how you can profit from
orderflow trading, visit my website,
www.orderflows.com.
And thanks, and I hope to see you on the
inside. Bye-bye.